zum ersten mal in der geschichte der
astronomie konnte die kollision zweier
neutronensterne mit gravitationswellen
und weiteren messwerten einer solchen
katastrophe erfasst werden und die
ergebnisse sind absolut bahn brechen
denn jetzt gibt es eine weitere quelle
zur berechnung der hubble konstante denn
das ist sie unglaublich wichtige zahlen
zur berechnung der expansion des
universums nur ist sie bisher noch nicht
exakt gefunden worden
die expansion des universums kann ihr
geheimnis jetzt gelüftet werden klicks
um science im future die gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst nichts los
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist entstanden in
kooperation mit weekly de dem digitalen
abos für smartphone oder tablet für nur
regulieren 999 gibt es nahezu alle
magazine und zeitschriften der link ist
hier unter me mit einem besonders
günstigen sonderangebot für euch hier
unter dem link gibt es die ersten beiden
monate für nur insgesamt einen euro 99
und danach neun euro 99 und es kann
jederzeit gekündigt werden und wir haben
dieses mega spannende thema dort auf wtd
in spektrum sterne und weltraum gefunden
für mich ist riet video nummer eins
inspirationsquelle hier finde ich nicht
nur bei spectrum spannende themen und
hintergrundinfos und auch zu einem
meiner lieblingsthemen kann ich hier in
allen möglichen zeitschriften
recherchieren oder alles wichtige zur
umwelt und ökologie finde ich in natur
aber es gibt noch mehr als 5000 weitere
magazine dazu auf wie die wichtig ist
wie das netflix für magazine
ja wir hatten schon darüber berichtet
umso genauer man den wert der hubble
konstante bestimmen will desto
unterschiedlicher werden die ergebnisse
die hubble konstante beschreibt wie
schnell sich das universum ausdehnt das
ist wirklich ziemlich verrückt umso mehr
wir uns mit der hubble konstante
beschäftigen desto weniger können wir
sie wirklich bestimmen die forschenden
versuchen bei jedem verfahren ein
möglichst exaktes ergebnis zu erzielen
aber je nach verfahren sind die
ergebnisse vollkommen anders die hubble
konstante beschreibt dabei keine feste
geschwindigkeit sondern die zunahme der
geschwindigkeit mit steigender
entfernung sie wird pro megaparsec
das entspricht einer entfernung von drei
millionen 260.000 lichtjahren und dieser
wert liegt bei ja das ist eben
unterschiedlich je nachdem was man misst
namensgeber edwin hubble lag bei seinen
eigenen messungen noch komplett daneben
der hatte sterne verwechselt und kam so
auf ein ergebnis von 500 kilometern pro
sekunde und megaparsec also pro
megaparsec nahm die geschwindigkeit laut
hubble um 500 kilometer pro sekunde zu
eine galaxie also die ein megaparsec von
uns entfernt ist würde sich nach hubble
berechnung mit 500 kilometern pro
sekunde von uns entfernen eine galaxie
im abstand von zwei megaparsec doppelt
so schnell also mit 1000 kilometern pro
sekunde und so weiter und so fort das
prinzip ist x-mal überprüft worden und
gilt nur der wert bei hubble lag
komplett daneben er hatte eben sterne
verwechselt heute gibt es drei
verschiedene arten von stern bei denen
die astronomie so viel über sie weiß
dass sie entfernung und geschwindigkeit
exakt bestimmen kann aber auch mit der
kosmischen hintergrundstrahlung oder
gravitationslinsen lässt sich die hubble
konstante bestimmen von all diesen
kosmischen phänomen gibt es so viele
informationen dass die hubble konstante
exakt bestimmt werden kann
nur diese exakten ergebnisse sind
grundverschieden erst anfang der
zehnerjahre wurden die daten des blank
weltraumteleskops veröffentlicht es
lieferte die bislang detailreichsten
karte der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung und eine hubble
konstante von 67,7 vier kilometern pro
sekunde je megaparsec ich das spitzer
weltraumteleskop lieferte dagegen davor
einen wert von 74,3 das
hubble-weltraumteleskop bcv ihnen das
sind bestimmte sterne und supernovae vom
typ 1a 74,2 die beiden werte liegen ja
wenigstens einigermaßen beieinander und
wenn man berücksichtigt dass beide
messungen eine abweichung von plus minus
2,1 kilometer pro sekunde und megaparsec
bei spitzer und 3,6 bahn
hubble-weltraumteleskop zu lassen dann
decken sich die ergebnisse fasst und
wieder an dass die messung an
gravitationslinsen also so starken
gravitations feldern zum beispiel um
galaxien die das licht von objekten wie
eine linse so stark krümmen
dass galaxien dahinter zwei oder sogar
vier mal auftauchen
dabei legt das licht unterschiedliche
wege zum einen sind es tatsächlich
umwege durch die krümmung der raumzeit
in der gravitationslinse und zum anderen
unterliegt ein lichtstrahl der durch den
dichteren teil der gravitationslinse zu
uns gelangt größeren relativistischen
effekten das heißt einer großen zeit
delegation die zeit im lichtstrahl läuft
langsam an das sind effekte von einigen
wochen und monaten das ergebnis 69,7
kilometer pro sekunde und megaparsec und
jetzt kommt die erste und einzige mit
gravitationswellen detektoren
aufgespürte kollision von
neutronensternen dazu
das könnte etwas licht in das chaos
bringen neutronensterne haben die
dichteste masse die ein sichtbares
objekt im weltall haben kann wenn
supernovae zu klein sind und nicht zu
einem schwarzen loch zusammenstürzen
dann stürzen sie zusammen zu einem
neutronenstern neutronensterne sind auch
ganz extreme objekt im weltall die den
verrückten eigenschaften von schwarzen
löchern schon sehr nahe kommt sie sind
so dicht dass dort zum teil keine atome
mehr existieren elementarteilchen nehmen
hier ganz andere formen an
neutronensterne sind dabei ungefähr so
schwer wie ein bis zweieinhalb sonnen
haben aber nur einen durchmesser von 16
bis 30 kilometern zum vergleich die
sonne hat einen durchmesser von rund 1,4
millionen kilometern sprich hier ist
eine extrem große masse zu einem sehr
kleinen gebilde zusammengeschrumpft und
wie in spektrum sterne und weltraum zu
lesen ist wiegt 1 teelöffel
neutronenstern etwa eine milliarde
tonnen absolut unglaublich ihre
atmosphäre ist nur wenige zentimeter
liegt die atmosphäre besteht zwar noch
aus atomen nämlich wasserstoff und
helium
aber darunter wird alles auseinander
gerissen in der äußeren küste sind
atomkerne und freie elektronen und je
tiefer man bringt werden die atome immer
weiter zerpflückt bis im kern
wahrscheinlich nur noch quax und über
ronan die nicht zur normalen materie
gehören existieren also schon ziemlich
verrückt was da in neutronensternen
passiert aber noch verrücktere es
passiert wenn sie kollidieren und man
kann mittels der multi-messenger
astronomie eine menge darüber erfahren
im rahmen unserer berichterstattung über
gravitationswellen haben wir immer öfter
über diese methode berichtet
es werden bei einem solchen ereignis
eben nicht nur gravitationswellen
beobachtet sondern mit anderen
teleskopen auch andere phänomene wie
röntgenstrahlung zum beispiel so dass
immer mehr daten aus den
unterschiedlichsten quellen bei einem
solchen ereignis aufgezeichnet werden
und bei der kollision zweier
neutronensterne am 17 august 2017 wurden
nicht nur zum ersten mal
gravitationswellen bei einem solchen
ereignis aufgefangen sondern auch
zahlreiche weitere signale und das wird
jetzt zu ziemlich spannenden
erkenntnissen auch was die hubble
konstante betrifft die kollision zweier
neutronensterne ist ein ziemlich
spannendes ereignis denn ohne sie wäre
die finanzwelt auf der erde um einiges
ärmer denn dort entstehen so wertvolle
substanzen wie gold und platin
zum hintergrund nur durch sterne
verfügen wir überhaupt über mehr
elemente als nur wasserstoff und helium
denn bevor ihn sternen oder bei deren
gewaltigen explosionen in supernovae aus
ihnen weitere elemente fusioniert worden
gab es fast nur wasserstoff und helium
sprich alle elemente auch hier auf der
erde bis auf wasserstoff helium und ein
wenig lithium und beryllium wurde in
irgendeinem stern produziert und gold
und platin als sehr schwere atome
brauchen dazu eine menge energie und
druck das gold atom enthält 79 protonen
zum vergleich wasserstoff 1 und helium
zwei protonen und eine menge energie und
druck gibt es bei der kollision zweier
neutronensterne bei diesem
gravitationswellen ereignis gw 17 08 17
wurde bisher zum ersten und zum letzten
mal eine solche kollision beobachtet und
es konnten eine menge erkenntnisse
erlangt werden jetzt weiß man zum
beispiel mehr über den durchmesser
solcher sterne
er liegt zwischen 22 und 25 zwei
kilometern und eben auch die habe
konstante konnte zum ersten mal mit den
daten der kollision zweier
neutronensterne berechnet werden das
ergebnis mittels der zahlreichen daten
die durch die multi messenger astronomie
gewonnen werden konnten
66 zwei kilometer pro sekunde pro
megabyte und damit liegt dieses ergebnis
unter 70 kilometern pro sekunde nah am
ergebnis der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung und mit einer
messunsicherheit von etwas mehr als vier
kilometern pro sekunde und megaparsec
deckt es
mit dem ergebnis der
hintergrundstrahlung aber nicht mit dem
der supernova-explosionen das spannende
es gibt ein weiteres ergebnis für die
hubble konstante und das mit einer
vollkommen neuen methode damit kommen
wir wieder ihrer bestimmung einen großen
schritt näher und können das rätsel um
die unterschiedlichen ergebnisse
vielleicht schon bald lösen das thema
stammt aus wie die de eine app die ich
einfach phänomenal finde weil ich da
wirklich alles finde wie zum beispiel
hier neutronensterne beflügeln
kosmologie und kernphysik in spektrum
sterne und weltraum allein für dieses
magazin lohnt sich schon das radlabor
aber es gibt noch so viele andere
magazine für mich und meine interessen
technology review space oder bild der
wissenschaft aber auf willi gibt es noch
weitere mehr als 5000 magazine das
sonderangebot für euch gibt's hier
einfach draufklicken der link ist
übrigens auch in der video beschreibung
also drauf klicken und los geht's bis
dann bleib dran